foreign
yeah watching Rihanna prove she really
sparkles from head to toe
find light in the beautiful sea I chose
to be happy be expecting mom drops her
new look on Tick Tock
[Music]
strutting down a hallway as she puts her
Diamond toe ring on full display
[Music]
it was one of those things over on the
Maker's Instagram page the company notes
that it's a 9 carat pear-shaped taurine
or as Rihanna refers to the Rock in her
caption it's a quiet luxury
[Music]
this comes nearly a month after the
accessories debut when it was part of
the Grammy winners Ensemble ahead of the
Met Gala
[Music]
of course it was all just a pregame for
her look on Fashion's biggest night
foreign
how's the little man doing growing big
beautiful happy baby thank you for
asking yep ASAP Rocky couldn't help but
Rave over their baby boy
[Music]
please
she just celebrated his first birthday
right around the time we finally learned
the little guy's name Riza
[Music]
ask for how pregnancy is treating reread
this time around I think different from
the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea
everything's different but I'm enjoying
it I'm enjoying it I feel good I feel
energetic
thank you so much and it looks like that
little guy of yours is pretty energetic
and so happy I'm obsessed and I don't
even feel guilty about it
well no word yet on when the Navy can
gush over baby number two but in the
meantime Rihanna's fans can celebrate
her latest fashion statement you know it
really feels Like A lot's happening all
at once